hey jc thank you we are getting ready
for st patrick's day it's coming up in
just a few days on thursday and many of
us will be you know doing the green beer
but our next guest has a few other
options so let's welcome back to the
show wendy forest who is the president
of nevada craft brewers association and
she is also the owner of craft house
brewery thank you so much for being here
yes thanks for having us i walked up and
i said oh no i didn't wear green but
it's okay i have a few days to prepare
so let's talk about it and uh i gotta
admit the first thing that caught my eye
over here was that there was chocolate
on the table so we're talking about a
lot of great delicious flavors here
today so all these beers are brewed
right here in nevada um so when you're
going to purchase beer for st patrick's
day choose local but uh these two beers
here they feature fun dessert flavors of
chocolate marshmallows s'mores and
cherries what yeah okay i'm amazed by
this i you know i love anything good to
drink but when you tell me there's some
sweetness in that i'm really excited
about it all right let's keep moving
through some of our options here and
then we can try some sure so these two
here um they feature oatmeal in that so
it gives you a nice creamy mouth feel oh
my gosh and these ones down here brewers
love to barrel age their beer so
these stouts russian imperial stouts
those are aged on whiskey barrels wow
okay yeah forget the traditional green
beer we got some good stuff here we want
flavor we do we want it and even i can
just smell that there's a lot of flavor
in these so let's try a few tell me
which one should i start with um if you
want to try that one okay so that one is
by my brewery craft house okay and we
used uh local coffee beans for investor
coffee roasters downtown in the arts
district you can't go wrong with coffee
and stouts roasted and roasted goes
together hand in hand wow and it's funny
when you take the first step it doesn't
hit you right away and then after i just
i taste it it's delicious okay let's
move on to our next option over here the
next one is a grape vase and that's
their outlaw milk stout so that uses
milk sugar in there so you should have a
little bit of residual sweetness and
that one has won uh many many medals
that's got a lot of flavor packed in
there yeah i like that one yeah all
right let's move on number three here
this is hauling oats by um tenea creek
and that one again has the oatmeal in
there and that kind of gives you the
creamy mouthfeel
[Music]
okay we're ready for st patrick's day
we're starting early if anyone says
that's okay we're doing it and something
that i really love that you guys make it
easy for people to find out where they
can get the local you know breweries and
find you know you want to support local
where can they go to get that list yes
so you can go to the nevada craft
brewers website which is nvbeer.com and
it has a link to all of our members
across the state that's so fun and a
great way to celebrate st patrick's day
and i feel like i deserve a pinch for
not wearing the green but it's all right
we're just celebrating early and i gotta
ask you do you have do you have a
favorite on the table here
well i am partial to my own but if i had
to pick a second it would be the outlaw
milk stout from great basin well i love
it thank you so much for always keeping
us informed making it fun and we always
get the party started here
cheers let's do the big cheers i got two
in my hand you know we're ready for st
patrick's day thank you so much